all right Napoleon yes sir Napoleon oh
where'd you grow up where are you from
uh I grew up in South Central Los
Angeles off of 92nd and Hoover Street
tell me about your family
well yeah I got four sisters I got three
older brothers
mom's no longer here she died in 2020 my
Pop's still living
uh we grew up in the system
why'd your parents lose you uh they was
on drugs and and gang banging in the
streets and you know doing what they do
we were
we were giving to our grandmother
but we lost we got took it from my
grandmother because
um my brother my granny always always
said uh
listen to your elders
so
when she said that that mean my older
brothers my older sisters and all that
so my brother told me to go get some
stuff from Food For Less early in the
morning I don't know what time it was
about 5 30 6 o'clock some some was
coming up
me being seven years old
going to the stadium Brothers on the
bike which is a maybe five ten minute
drive in in the car
a seven on a bike you know it takes a
long time
so my grandma thought I ran away
and she whooped me
which I had 21 opening wounds on my back
still sent me to school
and that's how we wind it up in the
system playing I was playing sports and
PE a back star bleeding they sent me to
the nurse the next you know DCFS is
called
how would you describe your childhood in
general
if I had to say I would say like
like up and down be or like a yo-yo
because I never stayed in the same
foster care I never stayed in the same
house for more than two months
I was either fighting fighting a foster
care parent fighting for my brothers
hours you know school doing some dumb
[ __ ] or running away
the gang life started if you win I
started gang banging at 13 also
which gang I'm from West Side 92nd
Street hopeful criminal game
so you're Hoover criminal yes orange rag
talibans
tell me about the gang lice
looking to have fun to fit in
I'm seeing uh
my friends was my brothers my brothers
was my Lokes my Lokes was my day ones my
day ones was you feel me
[ __ ] I love and I would do any and
everything for the [ __ ] I love if I
tell you I love you
if you know the letters in the word love
l-o-v-e
loyalty over everything
that's what if I'm like I love you bro
you I vowed my loyalty to you you need
the last sock off my foot you got that
and you know my mother and father always
told me like yeah
um your loyalty and your your the way
you
are so stuck to your game you end up
going wind up in prison for life or end
up dead
I'm 30 years old
and from 13 to 30 the longest I've been
on the street it's nine months
all that time has been in prison most of
that time being in prison
foster care group homes uh placements uh
Mental Hospitals
uh uh uh juvenile hall juvenile camps
never made it to Y.A went straight to
the county jail to the penitentiary
um
yeah now I'm trying to get my life back
I'm trying to I didn't gave up too many
years
how long you been out
since June 10th what's yours fresh out
yeah fresh out I'm trying to do some
stuff I'm trying to get a bike so I can
do this ubereat stuff
you have kids
I do
I have a
eight-year-old a 13 year old or 15 year
old and my oldest child turned 18 on the
9th of this month
and you're 30 and you have an 18 year
old I started at 12.
baby mama was 20.
what if you had to put a point of finger
at what led you on this path
a lot of prison time and
um a lot of kids that you're not
watching
parenting
are you drugs are drugs part of your
life yeah I do crystal I do marijuana I
didn't try uh
hair on I didn't try cocaine not crack
but I didn't call I didn't try I didn't
call that I didn't try powder cocaine I
didn't try
uh sure
I ain't trying mollies and try ecstasy
um so what would you point your finger
at that
which is just the lack of the lack of
structure the lack of the lack of
uh
male role models did you have any role
models I really didn't
like when I got hard when we when I went
to the system they took all three of my
brothers and put them in one place they
took my two little sisters and let them
go my auntie and me my sister and my my
oldest sister and my second older sister
went to the same spot but that didn't
last long because we ended up beating up
the lady that was taking care of us
and running away
and we were probably there for like two
weeks
so
a lot of Chaos
I'm very angry
I I try to control it
just like
two about what four days ago says
uh
I just got into about three fights in
one day and broke my pinky
I haven't went to the doctor knowing
nothing to put some ice on it whatever
it is what it is but yeah like I try to
control my anger but it's the little
things that get me mad it's not really
the big things
you can call me on my name you can say
[ __ ] my mama all the [ __ ] might get mad
but I might not do nothing
but it's the littlest [ __ ] that gets me
irritated
the littlest [ __ ] that gets me irritated
but if you ask anybody that knows me
they will tell you I am a humble cool
calm collected love to have fun laugh
giggle talk [ __ ] to everybody like
literally
like joke and play with everybody I
don't care who you are
that's just me they call me a social
butterfly
when somebody called me that I thought
they were calling me gay the first time
and I'll beat him up
so yeah you've been in love before
yes I just fell out of love
I was just with like all right off and
on my baby mama but for the last seven
years we've been going strong but for
these last few months it's just been
arguing with us and arguing with fussing
arguing fussing arguing fussing I don't
know is because if she's pregnant now
because I just gotta text earlier of a
sonogram
is that the word silence
sonogram all right yeah I just I just
got a picture of that that she's
pregnant again
and
you feel like there's a lack of
opportunity in your life
a lot of like opportunities
and it's not opportunities that
presented itself it's like a
taking advantage of the opportunities
out of four scholarship the University
of Hawaii to play football he did
I chose the streets
uh it's like three or four people right
now I want to sign me to record labels
but
they're iffy on me because I keep on
going back and forth from jail
I'm like right now my grandma always
said
when you sick and tired when you get
tired of being sick and tired you would
change
I'm at that point where I'm sick and
tired of being tired
and what was going through your head
when you were passing on a full ride
scholarship well I wasn't literally
passing it on I went down there for
summer whatever to check it out and see
what everything was about and all that
then when I came well not summer but
when I went out there to visit and take
it to order campus and all that when I
came back out 2010 summer 2010 I ended
up getting locked up for a robbery oh
so that's what [ __ ] my [ __ ] off
that'll get in the way do you still have
hope of getting your life together a
little bit like right now like
I've been homeless for the last few
months I've been trying to hustle up 20
30 40 dollars just to buy two three
hours in a room
like
I don't got it like that
by what means do you make money how do
you make money I sell dick
what I mean by that I sell myself if if
I'm standing out on fake as you've seen
how I walked up little shorts no T-shirt
my God most of the time what about all
the gang things you used to do
um still doing sometimes it depends how
I'm feeling
uh
but no uh on to the home
um back to the homeless stuff real quick
but I did just get a trailer somebody
just you know
blowing me a trailer that I can sleep in
and and eat and all that stuff in and
all that stuff it's it's messed up I'm
building stuff and I'm trying to get the
water back on and all this starting to
get it to work but it was a blessing but
you have no support from your family or
anybody like that right I don't really
[ __ ] with my family like that because I
chose love
over the truth
when I came home this time
my cousin said oh my baby mama but I
call her my wife because we we've been
together so long so my wife whatever
my whole family my auntie my mama my
sisters my brothers my nieces my nephews
was all telling me that my wife [ __ ]
my pops
I did I wanted to believe it and I
didn't want to believe it so you know
according that loved love emotion and
and everything so I believed her over
everything so basically I got I'm the
black sheep as as you
can quote on the black sheep like
so they don't really [ __ ] with me like
that like if we used to go to a function
or a party or something I'm not invited
because they already think oh he's gonna
fight he's going to get into some [ __ ]
he's gonna bring some drugs he's going
to do something he's going to steal
something they already think that but
honestly I'm
only I only cause harm to people that
cross harmed at me only disrespect when
I feel disrespected
there's no reason for me to just come
out of the
Woodworks or the blue or out of nowhere
just to disrespect any man woman child
Beast no nothing
I was growing up with respect I was
raised with with dignity's immorals and
stuff like that but at the same time
some people deserve to get what they got
coming
you know what are you afraid of at this
point in your life
deaf
and that's about it
other than that I'm not scared of no
soul on it you bleed just like me you
break just like me you cut just like me
so I'm not scared of nothing or nobody
on this Earth death is a real
possibility in South Central
and then got shot twice already
that wasn't really a question
Yeah well yeah it's a it's a great
possibility but like I said I didn't got
shot already got into two for the land
you feel me it is what it is
it's dangerous it comes with it comes
with the territory you know what it is
when you sign up either you you win it
or you not either you come from this
cloth or you're not like either your
heart is all the way in it or you don't
have it at all it's it's amazing
different
everything is in South Central it's hard
to believe it's still Los Angeles oh
yeah like South Central is a rough area
like growing up or like
I I used to whoop out people and little
kids in school growing up for their
tennis shoes because I had holy fitting
shoes with no socks and all that [ __ ]
how many of your Hoover friends are gone
now like dead yeah
for all my open falling stars Grew From
over Street
a lot
a lot and some of my best friends some
of my Lokes some of my day ones like
like knee-high to a grasshopper like
these [ __ ] didn't
like
literally sadly bathed me like when I
was a kid like you know I'm fat a couple
years older than me and helping moms and
helping Auntie out with us you know like
and then my OG homies like that I miss
so much like on over
big Bambino first look tiny chill over
like like
dead homies I can go down a list I can
go down the list poochie uh touche
pld we were like ah get Sharky h.i.p my
local over my day one uh
I can go down the list but those was all
solid older and young at my age like
young homies and big homies and my age
homies like solid ass [ __ ] like on
over
and you're like
[ __ ] would say [ __ ] you to get like
weird talk [ __ ] to each other like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] we almost getting down for the
guarantee a [ __ ] that that we don't
know
say something about our conversation we
both turning on him type [ __ ] [ __ ] you
ain't got nothing to say about this now
we about to whoop your ass for jumping
in
like
that that's what my [ __ ] like we get
down and then actually no good we
smoking a cigarette or drinking some
drink after each other laughing about
the situation oh [ __ ] you duck this way
oh then you hit me over here like [ __ ]
like that that was my like
my real day ones my real Oaks
what are the differences between uh
floods Crips and Hoovers uh we a
different breed on West Side hoping like
weed like
grimy schniny if it ain't over then
scandalous if you ain't from the Max 90s
you ain't grimy you feel me one seven
one six with the six or actress I hope
we did that hats to the front
you already know we sagging fig but yeah
we a different breed like everybody know
what it is I don't have to really speak
up on the Gangland or nothing like that
but [ __ ] know on over Street [ __ ]
know what's your biggest regret huh
what's your biggest regret in your life
my biggest regret
is not being there for my mother's
funeral my dad how much you're in prison
I hope I was in prison she had a heart
attack coming up the driveway and she
just put her grand my nephew just put
her grandson in the car my sister just
pulled off
so yeah not being there for her and not
listening tell him as I could have been
changed my life I could have probably
would have had my mama here longer if I
would have did some things
a different form fashion way whatever
you want to call it but yeah
Napoleon what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson
it's a couple of about I ain't gonna lie
I say my top three is treat others like
you want to be treated that's the Golden
Rule
the other one is like
um
sometimes you have to take some time and
be selfish and focus on self you can't
do [ __ ] for everybody else
because who's going to do it for you if
you're not doing it for yourself
and
last but not least
get the bag here we get the bag are we
all over the street gotta get the cash
that's about it bro like
all right Napoleon thank you so much for
sharing your story oh man anytime man
you need me to come back and do it again
I will good luck I'm glad you're you're
free stay that way yes sir thank you I
appreciate it thanks man